what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and in a rare case
Marvel Studios before a movie is coming
out has actually confirmed some of the
leaks for the Marvels that we've been
hearing for a little bit now we're about
to show you a trailer that Marvel
Studios has not yet released online
however they are showing it in the
actual movie theaters right now so it is
an official trailer by Marvel Studios
released for theaters and it's a decent
length it's a little under 2 minutes and
it does does have new footage that we
have not seen before and some of the new
footage in this trailer does confirm a
pretty big leak when it comes to Captain
Marvel in the Marvels so we'll show you
some footage and break it down and again
this is showing in theaters you could
see this in theaters before some movies
that you go watch right now but credit
to ww Marvel for capturing the footage
and posting it online let's take a look
H are you doing your homework yeah
science what if you could straight
places with your favorite
superhero
[Music]
hi Captain Marvel is walking up and down
our living room and now you come back
Walling in with no apologies her Captain
Marvel was in her
H you can absorb
L I can see it and Cala can turn light
into physical matter our powers are
intang
so we switch places whenever we use them
I go by Miss Marvel and I hope that's
okay like I realized I should have asked
permission so
twinsies okay on November 10 the
annihilator you took everything from me
what are you prepared to do
s
switch everyone together on three ready
1 2 3 go now why would you say go if for
going on I'm aware get ready for Fury f
up fun is this an Avengers tack fly
where's Camala fashion princess I'm
feeling so many feelings right now and
flk it this fre cat
tentacles I can't can you I got
[Music]
it
the
marbles so in this new footage there are
actually a lot of new cool scenes that
we do see like Camala Carol and Monica
figuring out how to use their powers
together we hear them say switch a lot
that's something that is going to be a
pretty big part of the movie since they
are going to be switching every time
they use their powers ultimately they're
going to have to figure out to use that
as an advantage which I believe they
will do and I believe that's going to
play a pretty significant role in how
they actually end up end up defeating
the villain darb Ben we'll talk more
about the footage but the scene we
particularly want to look at in this
trailer is the footage of Captain Marvel
Carol ders walking hand inand with
Prince Jan and Monica saying princess as
a question this is a leak that we've
been hearing about for a very long time
now something you have to remember is
that Captain Marvel left Earth for a
very long time she left Earth after the
events of the first Captain Marvel film
then she came back to Earth because Nick
Fury paged her then she left Earth again
during the events of Avengers endgame
she came back to meet Fury Fury wasn't
there he was dusted she went with the
Avengers to find Thanos to try and find
the stones and reverse the snap however
of course Thanos had already destroyed
all of the stones and The Infinity
Gauntlet and then she basically left
again for 5 years until she came back
for the very end of Avengers ingame and
we assume that since then she's been
gone as well so she's been out there in
the cosmos in the Galaxy or galaxies all
all over in the universe for a pretty
long time she's visited many different
worlds and the Marvels is kind of going
to show us what she's been up to we
definitely know it wasn't finding a
place for the scroll to live sadly but
we do know that she has kind of been
helping people out and we know that
she's gotten married at least that's
what some of the leaks have said and
that is what this trailer shows us the
reports that we had gotten in the past
are that Carol ders goes to a planet
where she sort of accidentally gets
married that's where parkso jun's
character comes in Prince Yan because
apparently Captain Marvel Carol Denver
is princess yon's princess and it seems
that Monica confirms that in this
trailer she says princess like it's a
question like she just heard Prince Yan
call Captain Marvel a princess so
perhaps he said princess Danvers or
perhaps somebody else said princess
Danvers or princess Marvel whatever they
might want to call her but regardless
somebody called her a princess even if
it was herself stating that yeah I
somehow ended up the princess of this
world and Monica overheard that and is
really confused and is questioning what
exactly she or they mean by saying
princess and here's what we know Carol
Denver goes to a planet and she doesn't
quite understand the language and she
ends up being involved in a ceremony
that she didn't actually know was a
wedding ceremony she thought it was
something else however of course she
realized after now here's where it gets
a little odd because Carol ders did not
have a romantic interest in the first
captain Marvel film and in this film it
seems like she was married kind of due
to a mistake but she chooses to remain
married for some diplomatic reason at
least that's what the reports have said
we've heard that actually neither of
them like each other romantically
however are very close friends and they
have a mutual respect for each other but
Prince Yan and the planet of aladana
where he is from is reportedly the
reason why the Marvel's actually has
such a short runtime if you haven't
heard the Marvel is coming in with a
runtime of 105 minutes that's an hour
and 45 minutes which makes it the
shortest film in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe however according to reports it
sounds like the scenes that they could
have taken out of the movie which made
the runtime so short was actually a
pretty good decision by Marvel Studios
because this was posted online from
somebody who saw the movie during its
test screenings they stated Carol has
already been to aladana and is reluctant
to go back because she is the princess
married to Prince Yan in an accident Al
diplomatic mistake everyone on alad
sings as a way of communicating Brie
sings she has a lovely voice but it's an
awful sequence basically if you ever
heard of the reports of rumors that the
Marvels might be a musical this is why
apparently there was supposed to be a
pretty big musical sequence on aladana
when Carol damis returns with Monica and
with Kamala however it looks like that
might have changed a little bit because
when the runtime was first announced for
this film some insiders came out and
stated that the reason the run time is
so short is because they actually
decided to remove some of those musical
scenes now they said some not all so we
still might get a little bit of it for
those who want to see that but overall
turning a part of the movie into a
musical might not have really fit the
overall tone of the movie but we do know
that she is going to be reunited with
princeon we know Parks so jun's going to
play him in this movie and we have seen
not only in the trailers released online
but in this new trailer released in the
theaters Prince Yan show up and in this
case Captain Marvel went and got a very
beautiful dress and is holding hands
with Prince Yan so clearly it looks like
they are about to do something together
as prince and princess so that aspect of
the movie They are keeping however just
not the musical side of it not as much
as they were before at least which
probably means that they did more test
screenings for it and that part didn't
test relatively well but we do know
there is going to be a battle sequence
because we have seen Park sojun
preparing for battle and what we know is
darbin the villain is going to go to the
homes and the planets of Carol daners
Monica rambau and Kamala Khan where
they're all from and that they all love
and try to destroy them as a way to get
back at Captain Marvel so that's why
they would go to aladana because they
believe it's a place that Captain Marvel
loves because she after all is the
princess there and they want to destroy
it because to the cre Captain Marvel is
the annihilator which we've heard her
called in many trailers she defeated the
Supreme intelligence and apparently had
a pretty big impact on their home planet
so to thec she is the Annihilator but
apparently she is going to be Mrs or
princess Annihilator as this new trailer
does confirm that she is indeed going to
be married to Prince Han in the Marvels
so go ahead and let us know what you
think about this in the comments down
below are you excited for the Marvels
and are you happy or sad they left out
the musical sequence let us know in the
comments also don't forget to like the
video and subscribe and leave a comment
so you can enter our giveaway for a
chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick one winner at the the end of each
month you can also find us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
woof